he helps people who are in war
you know
casualty stuff like that helps them
so
um
that's basically all i know really how
long have you been out there
and he'd been over there before
and was on and came back to leave
and then he went back i begged him not
to
because of
russia's bad yeah
um
[Music]
have you spoken to him in the last week
and a half while he's been out there i
was on
facetime with him
up to 4 am
monday morning
what was he saying
he was saying that
he's going to be going off
radar
30
thirty
six hours thirty two hours
and he'll get back to me and then a
weird phone call for
purpose four in the morning
i got four uh got a message
um
morning
um
he can't speak
uh but he'll try he'll ring me
now that was weird because
he's going off the air going off the
grid for 36 hours but he's going to ring
me there
and i thought what sort of message was
that was that on whatsapp or something
it was on me messenger right facebook
message yeah
do you not think that was him then
he always says mum and he didn't say mum
he just said good morning he always says
good morning mum
so i don't know if it was him
i've been thinking about it over and
over and over and over again
and linda i ask i have to ask you how
you're feeling i come on it
thanks
why i don't know what to do anymore
i don't know
it's horrible
i'm not i'll start since three a.m this
morning
wasn't sky news
glued to it
rewinding it over and over and over
missed anything
recording every single episode
i said please don't go he said mama i
can't live with myself knowing that
people need my help need help
to get to safe a safe place
and i have to go
he said
i would feel bad
for them is that in his nature that's
what what's he like
too caring i wish he was a horrible
person to be honest and i know that
sounds selfish but
you don't mess with the russians do you
really
he's too kind
does he know is he friends with the
person he's out there with i don't know
you don't know him
no
i just got a message and all this blew
up and
i feel like i'm in my worst nightmare
now
and
i just don't know what to do
i don't know
i don't know what to do
i know nothing
and i just want him to
give him back
is your fear that he's he's been
captured what do you feel that might
have been
he
messaged me
20 times a day
he facetimes me
eight nine times a day
nothing
something's wrong they've got him
definitely he would
he would contact me if he could and he
can't i know we can't
he's gone from
me thinking i want to
strangle him because about 50 face times
and i mean they all say things in jest
to nothing
something's wrong
and all we wanted to do
was help people